maintenant Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
le plongeur en apnée Loïc Le ferme meurt
à l'entraînement faut remonter à la
surface sinon le record ne compte pas à
la Fédération d'apnée durant le tsunami
ils ont reçu des centaines de lettres
oui mon mari restait qu'un jour sous
l'eau pouvez-vous homologuer ce nouveau
record non au remonter
anthropologie les cheveux de Ramsès II
restitués à l'Égypte on est sûr que ce
sont les siens si on a déjà fait une
boulette avec Jeanne d'Arc il y a un
autre égyptien célèbre ici c'est Orlando
et si on restitue ces implants
capillaires à l'Égypte ça va gueuler
gérontologie Michel Drucker embauche
madame de Fontenay comme chroniqueuse
Drucker toujours dans Télé 2 Semaines
Michel nous présente ses trois filles
Olga virgule et son préféré Stéphane
caniche royal à poil bouclés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
showbize caisse Richard déclare avoir
sniffé les cendres de son père avec de
la cocaïne il paraît qu'on prend la
personnalité du mort donc gynéco a dû
sniffer un gros naze
neko saliagas Chevalier des Arts et des
Lettres
heureusement que le gouvernement va
changer qu'un jour de plus et Stevie
était décoré
Formule 1 en 2009 le Grand Prix de
France pourrait avoir lieu à Paris oui
c'est la dernière torture imaginée par
de la Noé toute l'année on fait du 2 à
l'heure et une fois par an on se fera
narguer par des bolites qui vont à 350
Joachim Noah rebelle comme son père
titre VSD voici la photo d'un rebelle en
slip slogie
c'est impressionnant
Pascal Sevran condamnée par les
prud'hommes à payer 30000 euros à son
jardinier une brouille idiote l'un vous
les couper la [ __ ] des noirs et l'autre
uniquement tailler les rosiers
et on termine avec William Leymergie
chevalier de la Légion d'Honneur gentil
en avion paye son jardinier c'est le
seul type bien qu'ils aient trouvé à
France 2 à la semaine prochaine voilà
Stéphane Guillon merci et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu